[Music]
well we've made some upgrades
hell yeah
we're back
that's right that's right brother we're
back leftovers is back in the 20 billion
dollar compound yeah we had to take a
hiatus to upgrade our uh security
systems it's looking mint in here you
don't even understand
we've got we've got sam systems out
above ground you know what's really
messed up
when
you got you got your crew over here
taking like tick-tock videos and
instagram videos from like this fake
like green screen area it's so wild what
the [ __ ] are you talking about bro like
he he will go in we he makes us go into
an area where there's like a green
screen just to take tick-tock videos and
then we go to the three million dollar
studio yeah because we well it's good to
have it staged for
yeah if you need green screen material
but you know what actually guys we set
up a free abortion clinic
at any stage uh nine months you can come
get an abortion oh no don't dude don't
go there people get mad people get mad
if you're if you're making abortion
jokes oh no no it's free here we're
we're fighting back
it's free even up to and after birth
i think some people need post birth i'm
saying keemstar you know he's what like
40 i'm saying if his mom shows up she
can still abort him it's not too late i
don't know if this is i can't believe
i'm about to do this i'm about in the
interest of fairness and my journalistic
integrity oh god
did keemstar actually have like uh i'm
pro-life but i'm also a pro-choice tweet
oh yeah yeah
pull it up i mean that's
okay i have to i can't believe i'm
saying this but i think that that
is a perfect indication of like
how insane the national republican party
has gotten i'm jumping right into the
[ __ ] part go ahead go ahead no but
like i'm giddy i'm excited but uh
yeah when i saw that because like
keemstar is the is the perfect dumb guy
he's like the perfect conservative dumb
guy who's like oh i'm actually a lot
smarter than i am you know what i mean
he like but even he has like a reasoned
approach to this and so does so does uh
70 of americans is just showcasing to me
how [ __ ] insane the republicans
here's the actual tweet
you know i yeah i saw this i was like
that's actually a
a pretty good take but the funny people
were clowning on him because he's like
that's called pro-choice bro he goes i'm
pro-life and pro-choice is like no
you're pro-choice yeah literally you're
offering people the opportunity to have
that choice that's where that comes from
yeah that's pro-choice pro-life means
you're not pro-choice yeah but there you
go you know even if even keemstar can
get it doesn't even mean pro-life it
just means you're pro-forcing women yeah
it means anti-women
is a term
yeah it's kind of surreal man so
frustrated i know i'm sorry keemstar
let's take it from the top though today
we're sponsored by babel
stamps.com and doordash
look at us
the top political show in the world try
again
like this
[Laughter]
so um how have you been i mean gosh it's
been a long time i had a baby who's now
three months old yeah he was very
selfish of you
yeah you claim to be pro-abortion has a
child okay bro
not pro-abortion by the way yeah
it doesn't real yeah
i'm not advocating for more abortions
let's just be clear i am i love
abortions i'm a fan do do them all
you complain about overpopulation yet
you're pro uh pro-life interesting yeah
well i mean i don't even care about
overpopulation i'm not one of those like
uh you know i'm not one of those like
dudes who's always like oh we have
finite natural resources you know we
have we're not in a scarcity economy but
um no i
i uh it's wonderful that you have a
child thank you another child
i am every when i
think
i don't know what to say in the
situations because i'm like i'm so
mentally stunted like emotionally right
you know what i mean that i just don't
know like i have friends that are
getting married they're having children
and stuff and i'm just like
i am literally a baby like in my mind i
know how old are you i'm 30 but i i
behave like a baby
well listen you don't have to have a kid
i mean it's it's
all right well first find a woman that
you want to be that you want to have a
kid with and then take it from there all
right we're we'll figure it out
but you'll figure it out hit me up you
just have to be a ten you just have to
have a tender heart and uh a willingness
to get [ __ ] on your hands and that's
[ __ ] it
yeah i mean that's fine i've had this i
was a it was a father to a puppy i but
it's you know so i i have experience
with poop handling i got less [ __ ] on my
hands raising my dogs you know but
probably unless pete i've had pee in my
face
because he's like a sharpshooter boy the
minute you take that diaper off
right in the face it's crazy how he
knows too he's got a sense for it
yeah but let's see you went to coachella
do a little update here you got called
out for your fits bro i gotta say i've
it's [ __ ] can i criticize some of
your fits or rate them go ahead yeah
let's hear it you have some of those
fits on that we could pull up oh yeah
i just kind of surprise i'm not gonna
lie so i saw you rocking that gucci
hawaiian shirt
and me and elo just like two days before
we were going through the mall
yeah this shirt and i saw that on the
rack i we always browse through gucci
what's going on and i was like who the
[ __ ] would buy this shirt maybe the
worst shirts
do you want to wait you know who that is
next to me by the way that's the tick
tock kid who's like
10 songs that you know you need to know
about you cropped his ass out he's
trying someone else did someone else
probably did that
i didn't know
i was i was stoked to see him he's have
you have you never seen a sick doctor
he's like ten songs like indie bangers
that you never heard about and it's like
nirvana i'm like
[Laughter]
but um i'll tell you what my mindset was
on this okay i come into coachella i
literally like tossed a bunch of shirts
into my bag
okay i did not prep for this this is the
oh come on
you're wearing a 1200 shirt no i'm going
to talk i got it there oh you bought it
oh yeah i bought it there the first day
i put the shirt on and it's like
it just looked terrible right and i got
really insecure because everyone else
was like blasting fits yeah and
coachella is like it's whack uh
everybody is it whack is she's
did you have fun across the board i
think are whack
like straight up i just go because fomo
and and i go because like all my friends
are going
and you know it's there's like there's
fun to be had all right let me see this
but anyway that's why i bought the shirt
which by the way is inexcusably
expensive uh your proportions are so
[ __ ] up bro i don't even know what to
comment on this
the shirt is massive i love that i like
the shirt though i do like the shirt
yeah but then the pants appear to be a
little small
yeah i mean i i like uh you like them
tight yeah i like i like short shorts
you get you gotta listen i'm i'm doing
leg day i'm not skipping that yeah you
want to show it if you got it i want it
yeah this one's better though i'm
letting the puppies breathe on that one
let the balls breathe yeah
you want to have a baby one day
exactly right
yeah this this one's better let's check
let's see the other fit
[Music]
three days right three yeah and three
days three fits and then the last one
was like camo one like top down that was
the highest rated one that was on my
yeah but you were getting close there
was like a poll
and you were getting like two and a
half's every day one of my editors
one of my that's one of my editors
austin alex he's the one who got me
cancelled too actually um
because because he's the one who likes a
good fit
i like this fit thank you i'm wearing
shouts out the jpeg mafia peggy uh
that's his merch uh up top that's what
i'm wearing in the bottom uh shout out
to my boy maggie uh reconstruct studios
it's out here in melrose it's like
that's you know handmade
so do you get vip treatment when you go
to coachella or do you have to
you have to rub shoulders with the plebs
are you trying to [ __ ] give me
further cancer what's going on what come
on am i under attack what's happening
i'm just asking i'm just
yeah no we so we got um we got artist
badges
um yeah i got ours guest and i'm not an
artist but i got an artist guest
and from who i'm i can't say anyway uh
from one of the performers give you an
artist i i'm not i'm not at liberty to
discuss this okay so so you got the you
got backstage where it's all nice no
actually so artist uh artist guest now
there's one step above that it's artist
and then there's like multiple different
layers like there's you know backstage
yada yada like or specific stages that
you are performing at and if you get the
a pass like the artist pass which one of
our friends had um
you can pretty much get in everywhere
um artist guest is like kind of like vip
and now vip is kind of just like
uh a general admission but with like one
additional area that you can drink at
it's all super crowded i think festivals
across the board like if you're
especially if you're not like a huge fan
of artists or listen to music that much
and i don't
um it's just so inconveniencing you have
to wait in lines all the time you're in
the desert so much dust that you're
inhaling i'm an old man i just for me i
i would rather listen to someone in the
comfort of my home but i'll tell you
what bro i i've been to a lot of live
music i mean not that much let's be
honest but i go whenever i'm at a
concert and you guys
listen i'm just being honest with you
guys okay but when i'm at a live show i
go man this would sound so much better
[ __ ]
on the headphones me too i was like bro
this sounds am i crazy so much worse i
thought it was insane for thinking that
i be i i've my whole life i do not like
live music sorry i don't like it it
sounds like [ __ ] it
listen to better bands i mean that's
that's true too like obviously if you're
listening like acoustic music like if
you go and like this is a philharmonic
obviously that [ __ ] bangs live bro
beethoven
[ __ ] turn up at the beethoven i mean
no my my people but i force me all the
time but you know i saw a lot of hip-hop
shows live in college and i was like
always terrible this [ __ ] sucks yeah
but that's the thing like all of the
experiences that we have whether it be
the super bowl or whether it be just uh
you know going to a festival or whatever
like you have to do
drugs and and or like beyond some kind
of stimulant if i'm honest if i'm on e
then i could be watching i could be in a
portal i could be in a porta potty watch
people take shits and it'd be fun you
know what i mean tech that's the one
area where
i'm sorry
i think i blew someone's ear out
probably um
no we've done much worse it's um
if i am
if i'm at a festival
in that situation that's better
if you take e i just that went wrong
that went out in the wrong hole did you
take e at the festival no i did not did
you do any drugs i it just mushrooms all
day oh my god but well well there and it
wasn't fun
legal legal of course uh shiitake is
what i'm talking about not psilocybin
under finely sauteed uh portabella yeah
love i do love legal mushrooms as well
i'm a fan of mushrooms so wait then was
it fun considering your legal
consumption of uh grocery grade
mushrooms yeah i mean it's just like
you're brutalizing your body my whoop
like the band that i have that like your
what checks my biometrics i have like a
fitness band thing oh not an ad what's
it called it's a whoop it's like a
subscription service it's too expensive
um yeah
that's the they can find a better name
than what anyway i don't know but it was
it's a biometrics device right it's like
it's like a fitbit on steroids okay and
it was cropped well don't yeah well
don't you gotta take that off if you're
gonna do drugs that's [ __ ] cool you
know that's like a definition of a buzz
kill
we are about to alert the authorities
with how little sleep you're you gotta
take that thing off next time you do
much it's really bad it panics when you
like
it panics when you don't get a lot of
sleep or like when you drink there it is
yeah that would be funny if it did that
it's just like it's annoying and in my
ear being like oh no you're so it's like
your heart rate is up everything you
haven't got sleep your heart rate is
elevated
uh it it looks at your like oxygen your
blood oxygen levels like you can tell
that just from sitting on your um i
think it just like measures your pulse
and your heartbeat all the time and your
body temperature wow and off of that it
makes like you know
i guess predictions and they're really
interesting yeah
um but yeah no the things were [ __ ] up
but at least i walked 10 miles every day
and then i was having fun of course with
my friends so of course people on the
internet were like
oh [ __ ] that like it's time to get mad
why were people mad at you um because of
the the shirt because austin ox my
editor made a joke which we we make
inside jokes all the time
uh in our community but when he goes
outside there are a lot of deranged
people who are like oh people hate on
him by the way it's [ __ ] hilarious
that your editor who i love that guy's
so funny that he's like just getting you
in trouble with the [ __ ] posts all the
time amazing all the time like so people
got angry that the shirt cost 1200 bucks
yeah well i'm angry about that frankly
no one no one would have known like i'm
i'm sure like some psycho would have
figured it out and been like oh [ __ ]
this guy he bought this blah blah blah
people would have known but then he also
said he also posted that video of me
like or that photo that's a old old ass
photo where my hair is like super short
too from like 2018 or whenever i went to
coachella when i was going to the
shorties and they like offered to they
had already had a ride for the dobrix
vlog squad or whatever to [ __ ] fly to
new york
yeah and i was hosting an award uh at
the show so they were like you can hit
your ride with them so i hitched a ride
on a private jet
and so he he put that [ __ ] photo on
and he was like this is
the real facebook
look at this socialist like [ __ ] fake
socialist like he's flying in a private
jet buying like a thousand dollar shirt
everyone lost their mind they were like
people were just like
it's so wild people immediately are just
like i'm gonna kill you i'm gonna find
your house and kill you by the way who
bought the alcohol hassan
who bought the
alcohol is that i i don't know is that a
reference to something yeah
i don't know anything about these guys
the story of the dubrick the night that
someone got essayed there's like a big
debate about who bought the alcohol from
the underage girls yeah who about the
alcohol is sean i'm i'm unfamiliar with
them but oh do you know who was oh
i don't even want to say go ahead there
were some people on that plane go ahead
is it your your ex co
host something the treasure was on that
airplane
how many people were on that airplane
dude hey look man they were they were
[ __ ]
they were maxing it out you know what i
mean this economy dude i'm surprised
that she didn't make an appearance
[ __ ] too this was like
it was not a good experience for me i i
literally just like straight ran from
neon condom it was late
and i don't know i've like i didn't even
know does the private kit wait for you
if you're late or do they fly because i
don't have any clout at that point you
know what i mean yeah they probably wait
a little bit where's trisha
approximately in this photo back i heard
him looking at her oh she's behind us i
think i'm looking at her going what the
[ __ ] is happening
and you're tr and you're what happened
yeah i just i just sat there i was like
what the [ __ ]
but yeah it was this guy i recognize him
but
as the man it's it's matt he's he's cool
i like him shout out matt and this guy
taught apparently about the alcohol
that's what the rumor is is that what
they're saying that's what they wrote in
the new york times
[Music]
i i like todd too but i don't know look
i don't know anything about the
situation but yeah i think i think i
don't know todd seems like i mean he's a
nice guy i like him
well
no comment okay
well i i need to be more informed on
this i know you a you're allowed to like
people that i don't no problem
i'll see you 2 million on twitch
congratulations
well we are worldwide on that front as
we all that would be a problem if i
didn't like them
um congrats on two million yada yada
i had a baby who cares which ones is a
bigger achievement i guess you guys can
debate amongst yourself two million a
baby i think the babies probably
well yes a lot of people are having
babies not everyone's getting two
million on twitter that's true
that's true babies babies are dying a
dozen these days yeah and you can't even
get rid of them now so there's gonna be
even more yeah there's so much more
uh more importantly i know you played
been playing elder ring i just want to
say is a quick flex on you i beat new
game plus seven i've complete cleared
the game entirely there is something
wrong with you
well what are you doing there's nothing
else to play there's not there's no
video games out that are fun so i just
it it's easy honestly when you're as
good as i am at video games
dude you're you're new game plus seven
that's the max difficulty i i know
it doesn't get boring like you're
literally shopping no no you're chopping
radon for like eight and a half hours no
no actually my damage is so high i like
three shot everything where were you
what were you what was your build
99 strength 99 endurance 99 vigor two
giant crushers
oh you jump attack and it's like insane
bro you do like 4 000 damage for jump
attack and it's like it's nuts
so that's going for me one thing i did
was
armor everyone was talking [ __ ] so i
started doing pvp and i was just melting
fools in my life oh yeah it's it's
really funny because like
you know things on the internet you just
forget that people lie all the time you
know what i mean or people just like
greatly overestimate their strength or
their skill so when they're talking [ __ ]
and they're like oh you suck you suck
you suck all the time i'm like yeah i
think i probably do suck yeah you're
right so what these people were
challenging you
yeah so when i was like all right talk
[ __ ] get hit and i did a fight club and
i was just melting them like absolutely
throwing like 30 in a row
uh and then i realized like okay maybe
i'm not that bad
well unfortunately my character is like
level 330 so i can't really match anyone
we technically could but yeah you'd have
to join me yeah
well i don't i don't know it would
de-level me
but anyway
so you might be getting some smells
going on should we do the temple slot
bucket thing now we're wait
do you want to be sick for the rest of
the
actually let me play let me play this
clip this one's on [ __ ] believable i
got something here for you our hog of
the week right at the top here hell yeah
let's get right into jesse waters
making those [ __ ] water because he's
so fine
you know what i'm saying jesse
he made this girl's
wet whap water he makes those wax water
you know what i'm saying found it
found it for jesse water i don't know i
don't i feel conflicted about this
i don't know what he did but also
waters has never made anyone wet oh by
the way did they explain you have your
own monitor now you can [ __ ] on
screen yeah i saw yeah this this this
facility is improved dramatically thank
you man the technology here is crazy
yeah no we had break we had a
breakthrough so here's jesse waters
talking about how he seduced his uh
his significant other you ready for this
okay we about to make growth
water growth
just wait boy
this is one of the
uh premier fox news anchors did you get
emma to date me yeah uh first thing i
did i let the air out of her tires
she couldn't go anywhere she needed a
lift i said hey you need a lift she
copped right in she know this story no
she doesn't know the story oh
this is literally it's the implication
dennis
like this is like oh yeah i took my took
took my co-worker out on a boat ride and
i you know i was like
telling her about nautical rules you
know
first of all i can't believe someone
would do that and secondly to admit it
on air like it's a light-hearted
anecdote bro you're literally the golden
state killer
you are a wanted [ __ ] serial killer
at this point to have such a devious
sadistic mind to let the air out of the
tires of someone you're targeting you're
[ __ ] targeting her bro about to make
those whops water dude so here's what i
don't get like does he think it's like
1967 or something like he's like this is
such like a don draper era thing to say
and it was like weird as [ __ ] back then
yeah it should have been illegal back
then too jack the ripper even thought
this [ __ ] was weird
like now at least we know better and
this motherfucker's like nope not me i i
know i know less yeah i i i this i i i i
i'm [ __ ] speechless let's just watch
it in its entirety you guys just judge
for yourself but
uh this is the guy who uh is dictating
basically how people should think and
feel so one more time here for the
people i'm back when i was trying to get
emma to date me uh first thing i did i
let the air out of her tires
she couldn't go anywhere she needed a
lift i said hey you need to lift she
couldn't go anywhere i don't believe the
implications i don't i don't i don't
even believe the story which makes it
like somehow oh it grows it's true why
the [ __ ] would you lie about that that's
what i'm saying he thinks it's like cute
in his mind
it happened i doubt it it happened what
are you saying he's proudly talking
about he said she had nowhere to go she
had nowhere to go who was there
it's i just think that it's like he did
that but it's too much high effort he
probably like cornered her in the office
or something no he did that dude why no
[ __ ] shot should we do a poll
i mean do you believe him yes or no
i just think it's like such a it's too
high effort for him to like
like it's like serial killer [ __ ] you
know he did it why would he lie i'd be
like you know how i met elo i've roofied
her and took her home and she woke up
and she's like where am i and i was like
i got you baby
yeah why would i lie about that or or
it's like um you know yeah i i cut out
her brake lines actually yeah she didn't
go anywhere and then you know she got
into a horrific car accident and then i
followed her and uh rescued her from the
wreck
all right well let's finish this clip in
the meantime
paul
is she telling the truth yeah i already
it's okay
no she doesn't know the story she
watches the shows
you're basically the zodiac killer
yeah it has a happy ending
did you really do that is that the first
time he even [ __ ] got like you know
what
yeah even guppy's like that's gross
jesse shut the [ __ ] up
this is giving me uh woody allen vibes
where he's like yes i had sex with my
stepdaughter when she was like 12. but
but we're married now yeah no it makes
it better when you do that lifelong
commitment that's literally got a happy
ending tucker carlson once famously uh
defended warren jeffs and and i mean
trigger warnings all around by the way
we're talking about some heavy [ __ ] uh
early in the morning but
uh tucker carlson once famously said of
uh warren jeffs a cult leader who was in
prison at the time for facilitating uh
you know child rape okay just tone it
down a little bit through a sequence of
child marriages
okay well anyway he he did literally say
just say essay or r word or something
okay sorry child r word yeah just don't
turn it down i'm saying a different r
word when i say that i'm like
to a child a child r word
anyway but but the point
the point is that
uh tucker carlson literally said well
you know it's different it's like um
what's going on it's a
it's very different when it's a lifelong
commitment yeah like a lifelong
commitment to you know our wording your
partner yeah that you
married when you were a child well it
proved she liked it
that's that's what i'm saying like these
guys are crazy well just to give a
little more uh context to him letting
the air out of this girl's tires he was
39 at the time and the employee that
worked under him was 25. this is the fox
news network where roger ailes was the
head of the company he was out in 2016
amid allegations of uh harassment and
sexism bill o'reilly of course is his
mentor
who as we know had settled multiple uh
sexual harassment suits so okay to be
fair to them
stop right there that's the only way
that you can
that's the only way they promote you
fox news
it's like it's like a florida congress
person like you have to have duis the
more duis you have right the the more
leveled up you are yeah well ryan
kavanaugh is running for governor in uh
florida by that definition yeah so
that's that's just how it works by the
way ryan cavanaugh won two of our
lawsuits two to go baby let's go hell
yeah just to update you yeah good good
slam dunked out of court what was the
result of our poll uh
75 percent uh say yes twenty-five
percent say no or something he can tell
no lies
um also uh one last detail about all of
that uh he
left out the fact that he was actually
married when he did this oh hell yeah
that's me playing airs out of tires
[Music]
good are you thinking disney watches
like kobe bryant of taking air out of
his potential future livestock this is
what the dance this is the dance they
did at the wedding
oh my god
kobe
kobe oh we're back
um
all right so tim poole called us called
me out a lot since uh
we've been away but that stings he
freaking owned you friend he did
in fact we lost some sponsors over a
controversy that you're aware about and
whatever yeah they're back and
everyone's happy now so it's all you
know it's all good yeah i've made amends
i have uh i have a
sacrificed myself at the altar
i said if not who
then me
if not
who if not me then who
yeah um the thing i will say i don't
look here's anything i did here's the
thing i say about this okay and i've
talked about this on my stream because
everyone's always like you know
ethan is in controversy like you need to
talk about it immediately okay and
um the problem is like
uh we do we do eat our own like really
aggressively on the left i mean all the
time and and it's understandable i say
this i've said this even when people
were like mad at me for the leaks of my
uh income if you recall and i was like i
get why people are angry i get why
people are resentful um there is a lot
of anger out there specifically because
like it seems like our lives are getting
worse and worse all the time
but you gotta always uh use that
frustration and that anger which is
justifiable in many cases towards the
appropriate conduit like you can't you
can't uh just immediately direct it to
where you feel like you can make change
because yes your side is going to be
more malleable and and listen to what
you're saying
so hyper focusing on people that are
constantly on a journey to better
themselves is kind of silly
in that in that respect that's that's my
take that's always been my consistent
position on this for the past like
[ __ ] 10 years whenever and whenever
i'm embroiled or someone else has like
caught themselves in controversy i say
it and immediately people like this is
your fault it's like well i'm literally
addressing it
i'm addressing it like i think that
people should be a little bit more
even-handed
uh when when you know matters like this
occur on on people on the side of people
who
genuinely are empathetic
to the cross but we'll [ __ ]
take i will take it all
but then we also for the record we also
then create a situation where like tim
pool and them can do a [ __ ] touchdown
dance you know yeah and that's what that
ultimately was what happened is that
every conservative
pundit did a whole [ __ ]
tap dance on my grave
made it sound way worse than it was
they're all brought up to like the
jordan peterson yeah and like you reap
what you sow you read what you saw you
will never appease the woke mob kind of
[ __ ]
so anyway tim was like
he lost his sponsors
and uh i never i have never lost a
sponsor because i stayed true to myself
and we're like okay well we look through
sponsors
and we're like bro the only people that
sponsor them is like [ __ ] slot
buckets bro this was this i swear to god
he has vpns
which will sponsor anybody
and this and then this is the other one
we found
check this out this is a premium temple
sponsor right here
ever before actually i don't think we've
ever done this and i'm gonna i'm gonna
give a shout out to a sponsor that we
actually have ladies and gentlemen
helping us make this show today is
safeandreadymeals.com you can check it
out if you're interested it is emerging
i've seen this a lot slop buckets
emergency food supply it's like you know
pancake mix macaroni and cheese it's 97
bucks you can get a four week supply for
197 bucks i was thinking about it i'm
like all your food needs for two weeks
for a hundred bucks actually a pretty
good deal oh great that's what i say to
people i'm not telling you to buy this
stuff because the end of the world is
coming or anything like that i just
think it's reasonable if you've got a
first aid kit you have some extra water
you know laying around maybe just in a
closet and you've got some emergencies
and some slots but like civil war is
upon us and you should definitely buy
this
so this is the quality
the website is like patriot
slotbucket.com
you know what i'm saying so what we did
uh we got a value pack what was it how
much was it so we got our own slot
buckets i wanted to spa i wanted to give
a shout out to him
and i wanted to try
i wanted to try this premium thank god
thank god i got like that you know
listen i i'm still i still have not
recovered this is this is the premium
72-hour slot bucket kit
uh by temple we use code tin pool
ethan i haven't been able to smell for a
[ __ ]
the past weekend this is what i this is
my introduction back to smelling
hometown buffet baby why are you doing
this to me
oh yeah it's all sloppy baby
oh it's so nasty
and hey you know what if the end of the
world is coming and this is what i gotta
eat just let it [ __ ] rain fire on me
bro no but that's unironically what i i
i believe that i'm i don't wanna survive
just get just let's all just go together
all my [ __ ] friends are dead and [ __ ]
like i don't i don't you know [ __ ] them
i can't i can't stream on twitch like
[ __ ] that i'm done so
i want to give a shout out what is this
cage you like you're like
well we got a slop
it's a chicken trough oh
it felt appropriate to eat it out of
yeah okay i'm not taste testing this
what the [ __ ] bro zero percent chance
bro i just got take a take i just got my
taste back i'm not i'm not [ __ ] that
[ __ ] up
i think he's gonna break me dude pool
this is one of his premium sponsors how
dare you
okay i'm gonna here let's try the map
the oatmeal how about that that's like
at least you know a good time to have oh
[ __ ]
that's bland
i'm just going to give it a little lick
and yeah and you guys can get one of
these at timpoolslopbucket.gov
they're running a great wall right now
wait that tastes
it's it tastes like nothing yeah it's
super bland it's so gross it's lit
shout out tim pool oh this is straight
okay i'm
okay they know their audience dude this
is like this is this is soup
food for people who think water is spicy
dude what the heck come come bring the
camera there is zero there is zero
anything there's no flavor in this
uh this is this is soup by the way i
want you get a shot of this
oh god god help me i'm not i can't how
does this [ __ ] stay good that's what
so this is apparently potato soup right
here
now this is
is it frozen this is the end of time's
meal right here is making me this is
making me want to lose my sense of taste
and smell again this is [ __ ] awful
that is
tin
tinpoolslotbucket.com guys use
use uh
brain is open to the air code for 50 off
for the record for those who are
watching at home for don't try this at
mac and home bro try that one okay and
two it's 10 39 a.m currently like in in
thank you it is 10 30 wait first of all
there is no cheese in there try the mac
and cheese that's the one that really
got me
shout out tim paul guys
coupon code uh it's not my fault it's
everyone else's fault for 50 people
it's gross this is a premium sponsor and
this this is my
least uh this one is chicken flavored
rice
i am not touching that i'm that that one
is [ __ ] that this one looks like no shot
dude
look that one is extra gross comparison
what's funny about this meal is like
they don't ever expect anyone to eat
this because it's all a grift it's like
end of time [ __ ] they're like nobody's
gonna eat this right here we go chicken
flavored rice
it's frozen oh
mmm
we got that chicken flavor right slaps
well try that i'm not touching try the
chicken flavored rice [ __ ] shot
that's just like chicken it looks so
gross dude i'm not that's where that's
my red line okay
well just i mean knowing what i know
about the [ __ ] end of the world food
that are uh you know that's available
i'm i'm facing the nuclear holocaust
like when the nukes are coming i'm gonna
go outside no shirt no [ __ ] pants
nothing i'm like please well that's what
tucker says you should tan your dick so
yeah nuclear that's how i murdered the
trough
and i'm passing it back to dan so if you
guys want your own end of the world drop
temple exclusive sponsor i heard this is
what abe is using to train like that's
what he's been taking good protein yeah
this is how he's you know keeping him
fighting shape
yeah here it is
i always i always ask people do you know
do you even know where your first aid
kit is and most people don't so i'll
tell you this if you he always asks
people that yeah do you even know where
you're first i'm always doing this i'm
always going to people's house and being
like do you know where your first
aid kit is i can't stop asking people
i'm just all about preparing the show
you want to get a good deal on these
emergency food supplies not too
expensive hundred bucks you can go to
safeandreadymeals.com it really does
help out the show thanks for listening
to that spot by the way tim paul got
himself a nice little uh info disclaimer
about u.s elections robust safeguards
help ensure the integrity of election
results so shout out tim paul
yeah i didn't notice this episode was
two days before january so yeah 50 50 50
sweep uh tim poole tim 56 oh cool yo
this was two days before january 6 and
he's he's hyping it up trump rally
tomorrow boys let's get in there you
know you know the problem is though it's
definitely not me yeah that's that's the
coupon code say it again for some people
you know the problem is though it's
definitely not me
it's everybody else you got that last
part because that's the whole coupon
code so the one thing i will say about
like i guess i hate the term ally i
think it's so whack so i always say like
i'm a lgbt foe jokingly which i'm sure
people will take seriously sometimes and
be like oh that's right we got them but
um
you know i i i forgot i'm gonna use the
term ally here but like you know it's
not
like what happened when you got
quote-unquote supposedly canceled or
whatever what happened did you become a
right-wing grifter no no i didn't yeah
it's it of course not i would never
that's a viable and robust career
operation that's the best way to make
money in this game you think those are
the slot bucket people pay huge bucks
brother and it's not even just a slot
bucket people like there's a lot of
people who just want to hear what you
what you have to say and and obviously
like if you're on the left
or if you're even marginally on the left
like you understand that this is a
a pretty bigoted society that we grow up
in so um people want those beliefs not
challenged but instead reinforced and if
you do that there is a steady flow of
cash that people will happily give you
yeah
to say the exact same things that fox
news the most popular broadcaster in
this country is saying so
that's why that's precisely why a lot of
people go the i'm a centrist uh i'm
actually uh in the center now because
the the left has gotten
too out of control and even if the even
though the left can sometimes or you
know rad libs can get a little out of
control like you just
you just got to put your head down take
it and keep trucking you know i've i've
been doing this for the past 10 years
people yell at me all the [ __ ] time
you know i'm not perfect
suck me was anyone on the left mad when
you said that you would [ __ ] uh
who's the guy with the eye patch
dan crenshaw i never said a [ __ ] [ __ ]
his eye hole no i didn't say i did oh my
god
i'd [ __ ] his eye hole oh dear come on
ethan
trying to get him to [ __ ] cry on fox
news again jesus christ i'm just saying
um he's an attractive man yeah i said i
said some other some other stuff i mean
he's a bit of a he is not a short king
let's just say
he is not i mean he is short but he's a
manlet and he's not a king he's a he's a
he's a short loser with a very [ __ ]
eye hole
okay all right i'm not saying that
you're saying that but i'm proudly
announcing it here today people uh yeah
the the the eye injury thing was not
even about necessarily about like uh
the injury itself it was more so just a
another additional tangent when i was
making a point about like his own
personal sacrifice and how he uses that
as an opportunity to send more men and
women overseas to die in endless wars
for no reason well he believes you know
okay
you know he believes that uh
sending people to die
to uh
to make sure that they ins do uh what
are they doing there again
what in in the middle east yeah
just extracting natural resources
you know that's a worthy cause funding
yeah funding black ops overseas by uh
controlling the flow of of opium um
into europe obviously not the opium in
america
um you're gonna need some opium after i
f is i
dude you're are you you're now you're
like aggressively trying to get [ __ ]
i'm just having fun okay what dan
crenshaw he's a good guy
thank you for your service by the way
he's a horrible monster [ __ ] him um well
i just think it's funny it's like it's a
it's obviously an outrageous joke but
it's like yeah they're the ones that are
like am i not allowed to joke anymore
so when i say i want to [ __ ] your eye
hole no clearly it's a joke so let's see
are you going to get
and that's how he got an injury that
that was insensitive yeah that's a
well which by the way ironically the
brave mujahideen was a
a a reference to both uh the now uh
impossible to find rambo tapes that said
this is this movie's dedicated to the
mujahideen and also ronald reagan and
operation cyclone i feel super
vindicated because in the 20th
anniversary of 9 11 all those [ __ ]
documentaries started coming out and
everyone was basically saying like no
like we did this we did this in
afghanistan you know
so more people more people got to learn
that so awesome
you know the brave brain
fighter yeah
but yeah you could see his eye on the
ground there okay all right let's no
it's right there let's just let's just
move on from this point i think we're
you know
the right's gonna be mad
can we not sell humorous remarks will
smith is gonna slap your ass dude you
don't stop all right anyway
madison uh actually before we move on oh
we have a we're at 40 minutes we should
probably
bust those out real quick all right we
got three ads
buckle up buddy thank you by the way and
not one of them is a slot bucket
actually that's crazy
but first of all thank you to babel for
most of us learning a second language in
high school or college wasn't exactly a
high point in our academic careers
why not
i enjoyed it
uh just saying
putting words in my mouth
uh
i i took german
and it was fun you know i went on an
exchange trip whatever yada yada so now
thanks to babel the language learning
app that sold more than 10 million
subscriptions there's an addictively fun
and easy way to learn a new language
whether you're traveling abroad
connecting in a deeper way with family
or you just have some free time
babel teaches bite size language lessons
that you'll actually use in the world
world like ian did he learned french
didn't and not right in wait
damn that was good
that works what else you got
what else you got i said merci that was
a good pronunciation yeah i miss you
can i get a oh my sure oh missus
listen babel's got 15 minute lessons uh
that make it the perfect way to learn a
new language on the go
other language learning apps use ai for
their lesson plans but babel's lessons
were created by over 100 language
experts their teaching methods have been
scientifically proven to be effective
with babble you can choose from 12
different languages including spanish
french italian german
plus babel's speech recognition
technology helps you to improve your
pronunciation and accent there's so many
ways to learn with babel in addition to
lessons you can access podcast games
videos stories and even live classes
plus it comes with a 20 day money back
guarantee start your new
language learning journey today with
babel
right now save up to 60 off your
subscription when you go to babel.com
leftovers that's babble.com
leftovers for up to 60 off your
subscription
babble it's a language for life right
ian
we
nailed it i mean dude yeah proof was in
the pudding oh [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] we didn't we did not that
no we just aligned on that one yeah that
was not even in the copy that was nice
you know here's the next copy i really
got to put i got to give up the stamps
you love stamps don't i'm oh my god so
much and it's one of the great
government bodies right like they're
good
it's good to be great government body
well stamps uses the great government
body it makes it more accessible more
affordable it's kind of a no-brainer if
you go to small business inflation isn't
doing you any favors right now it's hard
never to stay profitable
but if you're looking at a way to cut
costs mailing and shipping is a great
place to start simply use stamps.com to
mail and ship and get access to
exclusive discounts and great rates on
shipping from usps and ups
it's an easy way to keep more money in
your
pocket hell yeah i love the music going
crazy right now
there's nothing more rock and roll than
there's a guitar solo happening like oh
that's why that's how i feel when i
think about the usbs
i mean i agree i did that's that's what
it gives me
you know for more than 20 years
stamps.com has been an indispensable
business for over 20 a 1 million
businesses
here's the deal you get discounts you
can't find anywhere else 30 off usps and
86 off ups
whether you're doing a
etsy shop or a huge warehouse
with truckloads of stuff
samps.com
is the solution for you
you don't need all you need is your
regular computer and printer no special
supplies or equipment
and you'll be up and running in minutes
printing official postage for any letter
any package anywhere
you want to send it dan's girlfriend
usamps.com it's so easy they give you a
scale
you weigh your package there
you put the stamp you put the postage
shipping slip on it and they come pick
it up or you put it in the mailbox it's
crazy come pick it up you don't have to
leave your house start mailing shipping
with stamps.com to keep more money in
your pocket every day
sign up with promo code leftovers for a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale
straight up you get a digital scale like
that that's wild just straight up no
long-term commitment or contracts just
go to stamps.com click the microphone at
the top of the page and enter code
leftovers thank you
all right
next one
one that i think we can all
give a big dub to
doordash
i use that i use that
on a daily basis
let's say you just got back-to-back
meetings errands to run chores to take
care of what's the secret to clearing
your to-do list a little help from door
dash you can get dinner i love
describing what they do at a time when
like everyone knows yeah i know someone
someone tuned in just now and was like
wait i'm in a door dash what do they do
again
i agree
but hey you can get your dinner
household essentials and everything on
your grocery list delivered you know you
can get groceries doordash yes
did you know i use this service
regularly yeah i use it all the time
as a as a streamer especially
uh get what you want to eat right now
right to your door with doordash
along with restaurants you love you can
now get groceries and other essential
items delivered with doordash you can
get drinks snacks and other household
items in under an hour craving a late
night ice cream forget that one key
ingredient for dinner or maybe you just
need to stock up for the week with
doordash get everything in one app with
over 300 000 partners you can support
your neighborhood go to's or choose from
your favorite national uh favorites like
popeyes chipotle cheesecake factory
they're like you can support your local
business or [ __ ] drive them out of
business with these other ones
wait what drive them out of business
well they're like they're like
with 300 000 partners you could support
your neighborhood go to
or you could choose from these national
chains oh yeah i don't know just trying
to inject a little humor yeah no i feel
you you know yeah
ordering is easy
and your items will be left safely
outside your door when you choose a
contactless delivery that was i think
that's like you know you got
sliced bread internet
contactless delivery uh as far as like
the intervention
goes i feel like we didn't need covert
to figure out contactless delivery just
leave it at the door
most brilliant thing like i'm not before
coving you had to take it from them
i don't know why that was the case i
don't know why it wasn't why we were
just never yeah
yeah it was were we afraid people would
take our food or something
um i guess i don't know i mean i just
i'm a fan i've always been a fan of
content well for a limited time our
listeners can get 25 off and zero
delivery fees whoa
on the first order of 15 bucks or more
when you download the doordash app and
enter the code leftovers that's 25 off
up to ten dollars in value and zero
delivery fees on your first order when
you download the door dash app in the
app store and enter the code leftovers
don't forget
that's code leftovers for 25 off your
first order with doordash subject to uh
subject to change terms apply
thank you then you can use that
percentage off to tip extra
when you get it yeah
so tell me actually i'm curious when you
order from doordash what's your general
tipping i max out there's well i use
well you can do a custom tip is the ad
over yeah yeah okay well i okay so i
you know i i use other delivery services
as well okay uh and when i do that i i
just i max out
or if it's like a big order i'll just
custom it and i'll i'll put you know
i'll put like a a good amount in there
well it's a good amount more than that
more than
it varies it goes from like
i mean i'm not doing very good i'm not
doing complicated math every time i do
this but it i i usually like it'll go
from like 50 to 100 dollars a 10
depending on yeah you give 100 tip for a
[ __ ] yeah
you don't what would you give a hundred
dollars i can't afford to give a hundred
dollar tip but
for me i tip fat i don't give a hundred
[ __ ] dollars i mean i'm making
someone's day for sure yeah so it's a
good deed you know um but you do that
every day
yeah
step it up i mean it's not like
this is this isn't a suggestion for
everyone i have the means to do so right
so that for me it's not a big deal it's
that is going to you know make someone
way happier than it was going to make me
you know what i mean having it in my
mind i just give like 20 bucks every
time but 20 bucks is good i thought i
was tipping good but i found out you're
reflecting on me
one thing i do is like if i go to a
restaurant and because i don't drink and
if i'm just like i always trip really
good 11 diet cokes i always like i
always you know double down on yeah more
way more than double down i always
fat in the restaurants
but i wasn't sure you know what the post
mates because it's just
i thought 20 was enough but won't make
me care now i mean
listen you know it's everyone has their
own thing
and i'm not saying i do it all the time
i max out usually you mean like 25 yeah
whatever is like percentage on there max
it out baby okay what a guy yeah you
guys go see
he he has the gucci shirts but he also
max out the tips on on doordash yeah i
mean it's it's
both of those things are well within my
means you know what i mean on top of
raising you know and charities and
whatnot fundraisers all right so we
talked about jesse making the wax water
we talked about
you want to talk about rover suede or
you want to talk about madison what
about madison do we have time for both
we have an hour i think we can cover
both so let's start with madison
snowstorm because we made a fun graphic
okay
so madison that's my boy hawthorne
oh my god
our wonderful uh conservative
representative
what is that is that a snos
jet ski or whatever that's called a
snowmobile yeah it means to be riding a
snowmobile on his wheelchair okay i feel
like he would do that he's into like
he's an extreme i gotta say i mean yeah
he's really into
he doesn't let the wheelchair like limit
him he does seem very oh he's very
athletic he certainly does not let the
wheelchair limit him whether it be uh
shooting guns at kimbo beating the [ __ ]
out of trees or
or putting his penis on his homie's face
i don't know i gotta say like on on a
real note like as terms of like uh he's
is a really good representative for the
wheelchair-bound like he you know he's a
good representation this guy's out there
you say he's a disability activist he is
right he is i mean yeah no he's showing
that like yes uh it doesn't you know it
doesn't
ruin your life and that's that's one
positive element but i i wouldn't say
wouldn't go so far as he's a good
representation of him like he said we
saw him clump his cousin's face dude
okay but that that's
that in and of itself is well first of
all we don't even know if that's his
cousin
that's true that's the alex yeah why why
is that being reported does anybody know
um i have some suspicions okay okay but
first of all let me ask you this is he
coming on your show
um i believe so yeah he he dm'd me last
year
and he was like hey man you know i'd
love to come on your show why do you
think he messaged rachel uh because he's
27 years old and anyone under the age of
30 it
is most likely getting at least some
level of political news from me
regardless of what their what their
background is that's real but even
knowing who you are is so interesting
that he would reach out to you
i yeah
i think he just sees that i you know
these guys republicans don't care like
they
they will put their face on anything
like they just want to be out there
because they their audience his audience
is not going to give a [ __ ] if i destroy
him and the marketplace of ideas he's
still going to come across as like a you
know strong champion of the right causes
you know what i mean
um
so i think that's part of the reason why
he wanted to come on um
he
it's like it's like when left is going
tugger carlson not
some of the people who claim that
they're leftist but like when chris
smalls for example shouts out the chris
malls of amazon labor union uh like when
he went on tucker carlson you know what
i mean or when um rutger bregman went on
tucker carlson and then they never
uncovered those tapes but
um well the reason he's in the news is
our boy madison cawthorne
said that he claims
uh he said in an interview which
hopefully this is it right
usually it's just like a long and
convoluted yeah i don't know that's not
what it is but it sucks oh god oh bro
literally oh oh god chris saliza with
that
to see you with [ __ ] socks with the
socks you know he's like oh i i love
when my face is on women's feet wait but
is there he's a bigfoot guy bigfoot guy
so very sus that he he's selling soccer
was this an interview he gave or was it
on
yet no so he went on the wounded warrior
project yeah i have a little project
sorry the warrior poet society which is
like some right-wing uh you know
veteran
uh republican guys i've got the quote
here i'll read it yeah
but he went on that show and he
basically wanted to flex he was like you
know he wanted to be cool to the to the
warrior to the vet guy in front of him
about like how he's getting invited to
cool [ __ ] and it's like surprising
he's a young guy
yeah
he's a he's very conservative
he's also a degenerate turns out oh for
sure
but uh he said in the interview
the sexual perversion that goes on in
washington being kind of a young guy in
washington where the average age is
probably 60 to 70. you look at all these
people a lot of them and i've looked up
to them through my whole life and i've
always paid attention to politics then
all of a sudden you get invited we're
going to be having a sexual get together
at one of our homes you should come
i love that i love the quote sexual get
together i that to me that makes it real
like i feel like that's some [ __ ] that
like one of these goobers would say
we're having a sexual get-together
he continues what did you just ask me to
come to and then you realize they're
asking you to come to an orgy
some of the people leading on the
movement to try and remove addiction in
our country and then you watch them do a
key bump of cocaine right in front of
you and it's just wild
so he
is actually you know if you believe what
he's saying is a pretty brutal
condemnation of the current of the
current conservative party
yeah i mean yeah they're they'd be
[ __ ] like uh it's not um
well ever since he made that then the
the minority leader
kevin mccarthy
destroyed him like he was he got there's
a photo of him i don't know if you guys
can find it but like there's a photo of
him like wheeling out of his room like
his office and his face is like puffy
and red from [ __ ] crying you think
you cried in there one one million
percent alpha though um
yeah well can you pull that out i can
cry he's in touch with his feelings so i
don't think so then that happened okay
oh oh oh oh yeah look at that
homie was balling okay um he got sharp
for that day though
yeah he was looking good i mean he keeps
it tight i respect it he's a handsome
guy i would say for sure yeah for sure
yeah so
so what ended up happening is after this
like he has a primary coming up on the
17th i believe right and he was supposed
to go to a different district and i
think that district got gerrymandered or
something so we went back to the old
district and now there's like some other
uh dude that the national republican
party is like putting
uh against them like pitting against him
but that guy kind of sucks and he
already got the donald trump uh seal of
approval and and when donald trump
endorses you and he's already been at
like cpac and stuff he was like he had a
lot of national prominence and people
love him as like the young people
um no it's never too late to take it
back donald trump has taken some of his
endorsements back through some of these
races but like his endorsement is
incredibly powerful as we saw in the
ohio race where jd vance uh who is like
a donald trump hater
beca who became a donald trump lover
he's like a peter thiel one of the the
boys right um he just won against uh
josh mandel who seemingly was more like
salt of the earth ohio guy like he was
as some of my friends over at the choppa
trap house a podcast uh say he was a
real soda boy you know he he loves sodas
soda boy
and and jd vance ended up defeating uh
mandel
and
and that was
i think definitely because donald trump
has a lot of uh sway in these especially
in these red states
so
he has already endorsed madison
cawthorne and and unless he like revokes
that endorsement i think he's probably
he's pulling ahead
uh yeah i believe so so and the guy that
he's like the guy that they put in front
of him is like he's awful um just really
whatever i mean so was madison but like
he's the other guy is awful in like the
boring way you know what i mean so so
anyway he came out and was like yo this
is happening
he got bitched out by the party leaders
and then the question is like well it's
at first i read that and i was like that
seems so over the top that he's just
lying i thought he was trying to be cool
like he was like telling this like yeah
wounded poet guy warrior poet guy like
you know i'm so cool
but
since it's come out there's been a
steady flow of obscene
hits on demand insane stuff that makes i
think all of us believe that this guy
was telling the truth because they were
trying way too [ __ ] hard to discredit
this man yes
uh coming from both angles so on the one
hand you have like the fire madison pack
and i believe if i'm not mistaken the
fire madison pack is like one of these
like ex never trump republicans who's
like a liberal now you know what i mean
i think it's like run by those guys and
they're brutal uh photos of him yes uh
this was the first one in a public
setting came out which by the way
uh he looks great here dude he's pulling
it off man he looks [ __ ] awesome so
this was the first one that came ahead
and only in the republican party would
this be considered a hit job right
like him having fun at a party
madison hawthorne if you are caught
wearing women's lingerie like you get
like you definitely get uh punished for
it regardless you know what i mean
because like that's an indication that
there's more there well if you're yeah
if you're if you're a saudi boy as you
say yeah
uh you're like what the what in the hell
this i ain't over supporting any kind of
yeah i ain't supporting that yeah that's
a man in women's clothing chiha woo i am
no yeah i don't think anyone i mean but
but the thing is like this isn't
political right or uh yeah i think it
was in politico so obtained by political
hard-hitting the soda boys don't watch
politics don't read politico that's for
washington oh but it makes the rounds if
they're trying to makes the rounds to
washington examiner national review the
federalists like um
those uh papers have have very limited
circulation and very limited reach it
needs to make it to fox news did it make
it the fox news i don't believe it did
oh well then
if it was a real hit job they would
coordinate with fox news right no
because there's two different factions
in the republican party the what the you
know madison hawthorne and others
consider to be rhinos and it's
exclusively guided by because they
ultimately have the same ideology
they're all monsters
um our ideology is that we're monsters
yeah for sure like cruelty for the
streak of cruelty you know culture war
issues uh obviously like melting the
poor
yes
so you know that sort of stuff
but um
the the rhinos are people who are not
fond of trump because they're closer to
liberals and they're in their like
aesthetic pandering like they want to be
civil
even if their politics are incredibly
uncivil and barbaric
so
those guys don't like uh madison
catharine they don't like donald trump
either
um and those are like the federalists uh
you know those are like the national
review uh writers so there's not a lot
of them they're on msnbc for the most
part so so the people on fox don't want
to show this [ __ ]
people on fox are i think for the most
part uh fond of donald trump donald
trump this is donald trump
they don't want to embarrass donald yeah
that's why i said unless donald trump
turns around and revokes his uh
endorsement like he's gonna be fine so
they heard but then so that was the
first one and that didn't do enough so
another one came out this is this
there's this is two of three yeah new
video league shows
is left-wing or not left-wing but like
they're libs they're liberals yeah
but so that's why i'm saying it's like
coordinated with both like
sides i see liberal guys uh that are
also like leaking some of this stuff and
it's okay did midas touch leak this
no i think this was originally leaked by
um
this was originally leaked this video
itself a week before the daily mail
uh the daily mail
article came out
because it was a daily mail exclusive it
was leaked by madison's uh opponent in
the on the liberal side some colonel
who he has like sanders
yeah no he he's he's a democrat running
against madison
uh against uh madison cawthorne and he
actually had like a boomer moment and i
think he like uploaded like the full
google drive document or something with
the video on it and then he deleted it
and no one really caught it
um
but i hope i'm not scooping uh my friend
here for
anyway i don't want to speak on that too
much but anyway let's watch the video
me too
so that's his cousin
[Music]
we caught him boys that's how the
conservatives here yeah we got it
well i mean but but it's important to
know that like this is something that
liberals are pumping too and like you
got like all right
i think it's fine for liberals to pump
it because it's just it shows what
hypocrisy these [ __ ] people are
they're just you know i think they're
being like a little homophobic but hey
it is homophobic but i don't think it's
homophobic to show up because it's like
this guy is homophobic
yeah all these conservatives or most of
them are homophobic
anti-trans anti-gay all this horrible
[ __ ] and it's like your own people are
are i don't think there's any the guys
are clearly just joking around right for
sure it is interesting how
this is a scandal so this is what i yeah
the irony is like none of this stuff is
like scandalous but i do think that
there is like some uh campaign
contributions that uh to the tune of
forty four thousand dollars that he may
have like given to one of his staffers
and he's like trying to hide it there's
like some crypto [ __ ] going on too
so they're like hitting it from all
angles he brought a gun again to the
airport
and he he loves like recklessly driving
and uh he there was like a another leak
that came out where he was like stopped
at a uh trailer of course
of course he's recklessly driving and
his legs don't work i mean that's okay
you can
you can
you can
drive normally without it okay but but
uh
but no the thing with the reckless
driving is that uh you know i mean
i think that's how he injured himself to
begin with so oh really he got injured
in a car yes that's how he that's how he
i wonder if his driving is better before
or after his legs no i think he's just
bad across the board and he's just like
he's right
staying consistent stay consistent with
her without legs yeah it's like if greg
abbott was you know going to the forest
over and over again so that was the and
then the big boy video just dropped
which is actually so graphic
i'm not gonna show it
oh it got removed from twitter holy [ __ ]
it said this video violates twitter
rules yeah well i mean it's like
basically revenge porn
territory yeah so that makes sense so
where did this video get leaked from um
you know that video i am not entirely
certain i think it was like this one was
intense
that one is intense still don't think
that it implies that he is uh gay though
like he's just there's some frat boys
boys are homo more homoerotic than this
is what i say all any gay club if you go
to the gym yeah you work out you're
you're a little gay it's the homoerotic
[ __ ] you're a little gay if you do that
uh one with same with like fraternities
same thing with like when you put
cishet men together in an environment
where uh they are presuming that
everyone else is also cissette
actually there's like you know that's
why like the whole locker room we can't
have gay people in here conversations
which is like super homophobic and
idiotic but uh when you put ciset men in
an environment like that they get gay as
[ __ ] okay straight up like
massively homoerotic big time
well anyway the video was him he was
butt ass naked bro and like humping the
bed
and apparently
it's it's speculated i think there was
someone under him
there's someone underneath him and he's
going he's going to [ __ ] wild and he's
just like
naked he's like nakedly humping
uh this other dude who has like a pillow
in between them i think and he's just
like
he's like trying to hump his his face
and that's something that like again
it's weirdo behavior that's pretty wild
it's weird behavior but fat boys get up
to weird [ __ ] exactly they're like yo
i'm a hazy bro bite we all gonna take a
turn in your butthole with our dicks
yeah no either it's just amazing process
it's more so about like denigrating the
other person in a jovial manner that
because
active because the act of like
homosexuality is is like ridiculous you
know i mean he wasn't doing that in a
loving because they're so straight it's
ridiculous yeah but but could be a
little gay like who knows they're like
this only i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna
be making
i'm gonna be making love to your
butthole right now but it's a joke
because i'm so straight yeah and i think
that like the reason why i specify this
um because like everyone is rushing to
be like haha he's gay lol or whatever
the [ __ ] the reason why i specify that
like no it's not that's i don't think
that's an indication that he's gay is
specifically because like
you know a lot of homophobic people do
stuff like that all the time
uh and it's not like it's not done in
like a loving manner
uh where it's not done in a consensus no
i don't think he's gay it's just bro
it's pro-activity um which is ironic but
it dissolves someone from you know
engaging in those so this is what he
responded to the one of him humping is
allegedly his cousin in the face
this was the dumbest thing he could have
ever done by the way he says a new hit
against me just dropped new hit just
dropped
years ago in this video i was being
crashed with a friend trying to be funny
we were acting foolish and joking that's
it i am not backing down i told you
there'd be a
be a drip drip campaign yeah he's saying
the drip feeding oppo research blackmail
won't win we will so what's [ __ ]
hilarious about this is like hey that
grainy like you know possible revenge
footage that you can't really tell if
it's me or not that's me that's actually
me i'm doing it
naked humping that other dude that's me
i want everyone to know it's me
i mean yeah
it was him though it was pretty obvious
i i mean he could have just [ __ ] not
responded to it i think because it's
like one of those i would not respect
well he's drawing attention to it now
yeah exactly well let's look at the
quote tweets i'm actually curious what's
the general response to this
stick to the facts your voters care
about
okay that's supportive
as a lifelong conservative this isn't
about we it's about you your immaturity
and poor decisions are coming to light
unfortunately
the voters seen this too late just
resign your embarrassment okay james
james harris is probably like one of
those you know like centrist republicans
that's what i'm saying oh great he's
israel wait he says jesus family israel
choose a side man wait first of all
jesus family israel what do you mean
that's like every republican in texas
well i [ __ ] hate i hate they have
like blue lives matter and then the
israeli flag next
like i don't like that trust me israel
we don't like that [ __ ] cuz i know what
they really mean when they say that they
say
we need them jews over there in the
promised land so when jesus come back oh
yeah he can wipe them all out mega do
megiddo mega dude we're gonna kill all
them jews finally thanks to jesus
yeah it's it's not exactly um it's not
exactly pro-jew like they're they're
conditional no
their conditional support for israel is
still predicated upon like you know the
end of the world where they get sucked
up into heaven and the jews still die in
internal damnation uh elaine mccollum
years ago you're 26 now you're i love
that people are actually upset about
this [ __ ] and not like about the fact
that he thinks like probably that
abortion should be oh yeah [ __ ]
outlaw of course because there you go
the republicans so that's the audience
that they're like uh targeting right
um so it sounds like he's gonna have to
people are really upset about this on
the right which is ironic and great i
think twitter is very different than uh
even the reach that mainstream news has
unless mainstream news picks twitter
stories and covers it in a certain
capacity which is why i'm saying like as
long as fox news is not covering this
people in the [ __ ] heartless did they
really never cover that
we'll see i don't i mean it depends if
if they decide to turn if they decide to
turn on them then yeah
yeah man this is a pretty big story and
i'm on fox news's website right now
here's one from 38 minutes ago i see it
on there 38 minutes ago
just dropped no no the fox news website
is not indicative of
fox yeah
they don't read right yeah that's true
but this is disrupter madison
blackmail after opposition group
publishes nude video
lol
yeah
it's funny because it's his tweet that's
really headlining yup exactly and that's
the point the uh
the article you shouldn't have done that
you shouldn't have responded to it i
think
if you never take the uh let's see the
comments here on fox news
cawthorne you have been one of the
biggest disappointments to conservatives
you are still just a child you need to
grow up even my youngest child is far
above your maturity level hope you lose
well that's a that's actually probably a
good i agree he's very immature i mean
not but like he's not immature for the
reasons we're like is it not immature to
hump your cousin's face and video i
don't know it is but i'm saying that
that that's the criticism yeah i'm not
gonna be like who amongst us hasn't done
this like i i've never done [ __ ] like
that but i'm saying that like uh like
that is nowhere near uh as as big an
indication of like who he is in my
opinion than like what he says on a
daily basis that allows him to like win
voters over
you know that's like way grosser and
worse
uh
well whatever whatever works but there
you go that's the story it's pretty
interesting i hope he calls on your show
that'd be interesting
i saw an interview yeah we're i i cause
i i wanna i wanna ask him i'm like so
what's up what's up with these cocaine
orgies like what's going on yeah
yeah he will after he got after daddy's
bank especially if he loses like oh my
god oh i can't wait i mean i i don't
care i
like i said it's the republican primary
i don't care either way you know what i
mean like what oh okay so this other guy
who's also gonna be [ __ ] awful is
gonna win instead like yeah [ __ ] at
least one of them is talking about
cocaine orgies you know all right so
we've got uh rover suede and then we
also have tucker's
uh big red balls
that we need to talk about
and these are both important so let's go
on to rover suede
the great leap backwards
uh the supreme court i'm sure everybody
heard by now
look at our studio it's [ __ ] cheap i
know what is this
you know how much it costs to install
that tv man i mean it's over here not
over there you know how much it costs to
install that thing
yeah just for these oh like i don't know
10 million that's crazy
i believe it
yeah so
we're caked up
i tell you what
the slop buckets pay well but not as
good as stamps.com [ __ ] yeah
so the supreme court they their [ __ ] got
leaked everybody knows the story by now
alito [ __ ] wrote that we hold that
row and casey must be overruled
it is time to heed the constitution
return the issue of abortion back
to the people's elected representatives
states rights by the way which you know
famously was uh
another argument that uh
reactionary psychos uh had and then the
little thing called the civil war
happened yes yes yes yes states rights
um yeah this is gross because uh 18 or
according to i mean some people say 13
some people 18 uh have trigger laws some
states literally already have laws on
the books waiting
most of the red states have triggered us
to go boom and and a total of 26 states
will be slated according to the
guttmacher institute will be slated to
to
roll back
abortion laws abortion protections in
some meaningful capacity and have
restrictions set in place
they're going to get significantly more
brutal going forward this issue is not a
popular one for the republicans that's
precisely why the axios leak showed
republicans uh urging republicans with
talking points that that were more
tempered and even keeled and to hyper
focus on the leaker instead
that will undermine the integrity of the
supreme court i mean [ __ ] the supreme
court um
yeah i mean there's no integrity left
it's like
it's supposed to be apolitical and you
have like five
christian brazil
zealot cultists literally
i lie i like that people are coming to
that conclusion because it never was
like when people think that the supreme
court is apolitical they're thinking
about areas of bipartisan consensus like
i don't know it's supposed to be right
allowing american corporations to take
advantage of child slavery uh child
slavery when they're that i'm actually
in favor of yeah that's you see that's
what i mean like i'm in favor it's
bipartisan right like they
that that never gets brought up or like
the janus decision you know what i mean
like undermining public labor uh you
know public sector unions and stuff like
that like there's usually
the the the actual political issues are
things that uh republicans create as
wedge issues like abortion which um you
know if you go back to the 60s or before
roe v wade
was certainly a hot button topic but
only became
this big of a conversation in the
forefront
um because republicans realize like this
is a good motivator for the white
evangelical christian base but even then
they already got them locked in it has
never reached above 30 well here's a map
favorability there there is not a single
state where support for a federal ban on
abortion has more than 30 support among
the public although is this a little
misleading because it says federal ban
that's not really on the table so well
this data for progress is actually
extrapolating this by uh by not
necessarily compiling surveys done at
the state level but instead looking at
like uh demographic information and and
looking at the looking at like their
voter profile
as well so this data is not exactly uh
100 i've talked about this before i
covered this but it doesn't matter like
in the state of florida for example uh
abortion or a ban on roe v wade or
overturning roe v wade has only again 23
support and i think 70 plus percent of
floridians believe in
maintaining roe v wade except yet
they're considering there's a good
chance that it will become uh outlawed
which is ironically not democratic at
all right i mean yeah these guys are
just straight up lying conservatives are
incredible what's the end game for them
then i mean is this is this something
that's actually going to galvanize
people and actually motivate people to
turn out or is it just going to be like
well [ __ ] us we uh i guess yeah i guess
you just gotta
i just gotta party the national
democratic party loves this because they
don't have to do anything they don't
have to actually like nothing ever works
it's like oh this is not is it motivates
like nobody's ever motivated yeah
they're going to come out and say vote
harder which they have right they're not
going to abolish the filibuster uh in
order to set like some kind of uh
codification of roe v wade joe manchin
and kirsten cinema have already said
that uh they would vote against it if
that was the case right um they would
vote against uh the the
uh the abolition of the filibuster in in
any capacity so we don't even have 50
votes for uh codifying roe v wade and
and you know that's just the endless
cycle that the democrats find themselves
in their their
endless ineptitude and their criminal
negligence is what got us here uh since
the
you know in the past 50 years there have
been almost i think 10 more 10 plus
instances where the democratic party
could have had the the you know
filibuster-proof majorities to be able
to pass roe v wade and or or you know
codify roe v wade in the form of
legislation that would make it much
harder to to defeat
and yet they didn't do that and the most
recent example of course is obama in
2007 saying he's going to do precisely
that and when he did have the
filibuster-proof majority um
not only that but he went forward and
actually uh reinstituted or reinforced
the hyde amendment that bars any kind of
uh public funding from going to planned
parenthood uh buddy why didn't with an
executive full-buster [ __ ] because
democrats are [ __ ] [ __ ] like
there's no other way to respond to this
other than they just don't care they do
not care they're [ __ ] terrified of
opposition but most importantly they're
terrified of ever doing anything because
they're worried that it's going to go
against the the interests of their real
uh you know the the real people in power
their corporate benefactors they do not
care about their constituencies in the
same way that republicans care about
their constituencies no matter how minor
or how marginal or how insane those
constituencies are because those guys go
out and vote
this is a perfect example of this
and that's why we're constantly uh you
know rolling back civil liberties the
moment that the democratic party takes
their foot off the gas is it wasn't
nancy pelosi out like campaigning for a
pro
for a pro-life candidate currently
there's only one pro-life democrat
remaining in congress his name is henry
cuellar he's a nine-time incumbent in
texas he's horrible he's a monster i
mean he's awful uh i'm actually going to
have his opponent uh jessica cisneros
who literally interned for him back in
the day and realized how old is it
uh he i don't know he's old but she is
28 years old and she's incredibly
progressive
an incredibly progressive latina uh you
know congress person or a
latina uh progressive person running
against henry cuellar and literally you
have the established democrats
campaigning on behalf of henry cuellar
right now you had jim clyburn who only
brought out like 90 people a crowd of 90
people in texas yesterday jim clyburn
that's the third most powerful like
democrat in the [ __ ] country and he's
personally campaigning
for henry cuellar a a a pro
life
candidate
that's crazy under investigation by the
fbi okay
that's disgusting get out the vote 90
people showed up
yeah 80 people apparently showed up yeah
get out there rally for your boy
like and this is completely [ __ ] up
and of course
i'm sorry to say this but mainstream
media the liberal mainstream media
absolutely will bury this type of stuff
like they don't they're not constantly
asking anybody like what the [ __ ] are
you doing they're not bullying nancy
pelosi and and jim clyburn
in in and asking them regularly every
single day why are you supporting henry
cuellar why are you doing this
what is it what is it what's in it for
you
like this is it you know well i think
whatever i think nancy pelosi just as
long as she can keep doing insider
trading i think she's happy i think the
progressives no absolutely
dude nancy pelosi is a witch
i i despise nancy pelosi it's bro it's
the end for money it's the insider
trading for me if you guys aren't aware
nancy pelosi is the
and all of his husband is the greatest
he's the greatest traitor of all time
and i'm not saying that his his return
on investments is insane yeah and it's
crazy it's like he has some kind of
connection to some kind of insider intel
non-available information yeah it makes
him a really good trader it's nuts like
how that works paul pelosi paul pelosi
he's the most successful trader of all
time right i mean he's not the most
successful of all time but he's not the
richest but like his his like w's he
takes no he's great yeah yeah well nancy
pelosi personally was like we're a
capitalist and you know we should allow
congress persons to be able to still you
know trade hell [ __ ] no no absolutely
not that's what you should [ __ ]
i think you should go to jail if you if
you or even your immediate family
members are
looking when you serve you have to make
when you serve the public you have to
make sacrifices
i don't give a [ __ ]
like you do not [ __ ] get to trade
stocks when you have insider info yeah
period um but as far as like galvanizing
people here's the thing okay um
the goal the demo hold on hold on hold
on
pelosi found and runs the venture
capital firm financial leasing services
through which he and his wife nancy
pelosi have amassed a personal fortune
of 114 million bucks they're just good
they're institutional traders they're
they're doing you know they look for the
fundamentals and they [ __ ] go to the
moon i think
i'm sorry i wanted to read that one yeah
yeah um oh [ __ ] as i was saying though
um so you asked like will this uh get
support right
so the the attitude in the democratic
party is [ __ ] yes this is like finally
oh my god an issue that we are like
polarized on right
that will that where we have 70 percent
plus support of the american people
right we we we went over keemstar you
know what i mean like that's that's what
the democratic party is a good point
that's a good point and um i'm just
using that as a symbol of like even the
dumb american guy the biggest dumbest
mega [ __ ] yeah even he's like
motherless mega [ __ ] so
yeah and
and there is this idea that it's going
to [ __ ]
galvanize people and and get them out
and vote even harder but what they're
failing to consider is like
i think how people feel they're first of
all first and foremost through a series
of of red tape uh like relentless
legislation that creates like
unnecessary red tape for abortion
clinics like most of these red states
don't even have active abortion clinics
except for like one or two for the
entire [ __ ] state
um
and even then uh they were doing the
bounty law in texas and whatnot so like
the republicans were using
like
the republicans were completely
sidestepping congress regardless to
already enforce these like
uh
these laws to ensure that people can't
get an abortion right to stop them from
getting abortions anyway
um but then also on top of that i don't
know if everyone's aware of this but joe
biden is the [ __ ] president and like
we have a majority in the senate and we
have a majority in the house
and republicans are still you know
whipping their dicks out and putting it
on the table non-stop by using state
legislatures and i guess functionally we
can't do anything it was like what do we
want we need 100 senators like it has to
only then
only then will be able to do it we have
well the truth the truth is we don't
really have a majority because uh joe
joe and uh christian chris kirsten no
it's our [ __ ] they're republicans
that's [ __ ] they are there but we
have rotating villains that's the point
the rest of the democratic party is
aligned with
their ineptitude they don't care enough
look at madison cawthorne madison
catherine got a [ __ ] pushed in people
are like basically [ __ ] one step away
from like pushing him off the goddamn
stairwell no we didn't
we're talking about cocaine orgies but
we can't get [ __ ] joe manchin to you
know uh vote a certain way what good is
joe manchin then he's a [ __ ]
republican he's a [ __ ] and he's he's
a liar he's not a democrat yeah [ __ ]
and i talked to david dain about this
from the american prospects brilliant
guy um uh yesterday and and basically
like
we have methods to whip
our our uh you know our politicians like
that's what the that's what dick durb is
supposed to do the the whip in the
senate is supposed to do that he's not
doing that because he doesn't give a
[ __ ] think about it this way
um
as david day incorrectly pointed out
yesterday
we could threaten committee removals
right we could be like we could take joe
manchin's power away we could say hey
you're no longer on the energy committee
all of a sudden boom that takes away a
[ __ ] load of his power he's making 5
million a year off of his brother's
company that he has like you know
ownership over his coal mining operation
and also on top of that that's how he
gets his lobbying uh money right because
he's on a committee
why are we not threatening to remove joe
manchin from the committee why because
he's gonna go republican no the [ __ ]
he's not
because then he would just be any other
republican and he would functionally
have no power no one in the media would
know why i don't think he's just another
republican
um they're not doing that because they
don't give a [ __ ] they're afraid of
progressives they don't want to look
aligned with them in any way no i i
think it's more i think it's it's it's
more than that i think they did they
just truly think this is a great issue
to fight over and if
millions of women in the process
lose their access to reproductive health
services they want the times when they
need it i think democrats love the fight
they love donald trump they love this
[ __ ] like the democratic party loves
looking like the hero without actually
doing it well let's see if they can
actually capitalize on it because that
i'm i'm doubting but i think this is
going to galvanize uh republicans as
well i think now they're going to push
for even more yeah
definitely on a state-by-state basis
they're going to be like we need to vote
we need to get out and vote because i
think what the with the supreme court we
have they're going to they can i can see
them removing gay marriage i could see
them removing for sure i could see them
making abortion illegal in the whole
[ __ ] country
i can anything's on the table when you
have five when you have the super
majority of religious [ __ ] zealots on
the supreme court yeah
but you know there's like there's a
whole lot of states
in like the south
where
there's going to be no access to
abortion for like several state lines
and this is just going to affect poor
people yeah one hundred percent right
people our people are gonna get
abortions they're always gonna have
access yes
republican congressmen and their [ __ ]
you know mistresses they're gonna be
able to get abortions their daughter's
gonna they always happens and they yeah
they'll even [ __ ] urge people here
listen to this pro-life politicians who
have gotten abortions donald trump
has rumored to have had eight women paid
off to have abortions and sign ndas good
guy
elliot brody former rnc deputy finance
chairman he paid 1.6 million to a
playboy playmate he had an affair with
to abort his child
you like that rnc deputy finance
chairman what about scott uh
i don't know how to say her name scott
desjarlious
a tennessee congressman he supported his
ex-wife getting two abortions what he's
but he's but he's pro-life
tim murphy was a pennsylvania republican
resigned in disgrace after urging his
mistress to get an abortion but you're
pro-life
scott lloyd former head of the office of
refugees resettlement
paid for his ex-girlfriend to have an
abortion yeah and this is what we know
of like is
pieces of [ __ ] because they're all have
businesses and they're all [ __ ]
getting abortions
yeah and it's again it's it's not about
yeah it's about shutting off black and
brown women specifically in poor uh
areas from being able to get these
services i always say if they were
actually pro-life then they would be
paying for they would want people to
have health insurance they would want
preschool they would want free meals
they would want after school activities
they would we would have better finance
for homeless and orphanage and [ __ ]
they're not pro-life they're anti-women
they hate women they don't want women to
have enough adoption right they're like
why don't you just like you know carry a
pregnancy term and and then you know uh
and then just uh give the baby away but
then they stop lgbt couples from
adopting children not them they're like
no they're like we want more we want
more unwanted children but no they we
don't want them to be because it's just
[ __ ] pro-life is just a way to mask
their own they're not pro-life they're
just pro-forcing women to
uh to suffer the consequences of of an
accident this one this one tag guys has
been saying all over twitter from all
the people like ben shapino down it's
like
you had sex you knew what was going to
happen it's like [ __ ]
the dude also knew
uh
it's not all like it's basically your
[ __ ] so you've got to pay the console
100
and it's easy for ben to say because
he's never [ __ ] well one job this was
a joke i was i was workshopping the guy
said it was too offensive let's hear it
i'm going to say it now okay and then
you tell me yeah this was a quote tweet
to uh
crowder i'm gonna say something i don't
i i probably shouldn't say he said like
why why he says if you don't want to get
pregnant just wear a condom
and i said stephen crowder doesn't know
that our word exists because he's never
ha because a woman's never agreed to
have sex with him before
okay that's a little bold cause you you
put the r word in there i would i would
just say like of course this unfuckable
loser has no concept of consensual sex
or something that's good yeah that's
good that's basically what we want or or
just like say something along the lines
of like yeah of course you don't know
that because you've never a woman has
never consented
exactly he doesn't he doesn't understand
the concept of an r word because uh he
doesn't understand because no woman's
ever could nobody's ever willfully had
sex with him yeah thank you like jesse i
uh take i'll accept my laughter now okay
um stupid bro
no it's just like uh yeah and look my
point was like look if you're unfuckable
like see yourself out of this
conversation okay if you especially if
you're a dude it's like dude you're this
doesn't
th these are matters that do not concern
you my friend okay you've
i don't believe ben has had uh has ever
had well i know he has children but i
don't know well i think with his wife
she's she's repulsed by him i think what
he does is he jizzes in a turkey baster
and then they're very medical about it
so he gives his wife the turkey baster
and then she goes and handles her own
business
but um yeah i mean the way he the way he
talks about sex is like again it's like
it's like talking to a kid like he just
doesn't understand it like he he
literally i i watched his video and i
was you know doing a video on his like
coverage over this and i realized like
by the end of it i was like damn like
this [ __ ] straight up doesn't
know how like that like he doesn't know
that people have sex for pleasure like
you right between two consenting adults
like he's straight up like that's
outside of his world view
and not yeah and it's kind of weird to
have that conversation or to kind of
listen to someone with that worldview
where i'm like bro you're
you're the [ __ ] freak in this
situation
well and also crowder's thing about like
just wear condoms is funny because a lot
of conservatives are like
no no preventative measures just [ __ ]
abstinence
no condom education no [ __ ] birth
control education just abstinence yeah
that's why
states where there's abstinence only sex
ed literally teenage pregnancies are way
higher you know it doesn't make any
sense bro they're so [ __ ] dumb
here's the truth number one banning
abortions obviously does not actually
stop abortions from happening it just
makes abortions less safe because
uh the carrier in that situation can
terminate at any given point and um and
obviously then they'll do back alley
abortions which by the way there's a lot
of women yeah
year-round what
oh there's a lot of pills people can buy
online now yeah for sure but the point
is six million women annually still uh
have long-term health complications as a
consequence of back alley abortions and
even in periods when you ban abortions
you don't see a drop in abortions uh
that still happens right this is like
there's empirical evidence for this it
doesn't even matter so that's number one
um
and and
also on top of that
if you truly wanted to some for some
reason like limit the number of
abortions that were happening
then you would you know you would push a
preventative
uh you wouldn't like wow yeah you would
allow actual family planning not crisis
management centers where they where the
doctors can legally lie to you and push
you away from getting an abortion and
you have to sit there and listen to them
and wait 72 hours to then finally make
that decision like in mississippi um
you you would uh you know you would have
sex ed in schools early on okay but
conservatives don't want that either
and you would make it easy for people to
be able to get an abortion so that they
never have to do it in the second or
third trimester unless it's like a super
large medical necessity and then they
turn around and they lie they're like oh
yeah these people want like late term
abortions they want post birth abortions
or whatever the [ __ ] if you're a psycho
ninety percent of this happens in the
first trimester yeah it's not like
abortions 90 abortions happen in like
the first like 15 weeks or something
yeah it's it's [ __ ] insane like it's
really
in like the third trimester one percent
and it's almost always
a medical necessity that was a wanted
pregnancy that is a incredibly traumatic
choice for the carrier to make yeah of
course it's
dude making making that decision is
really hard really emotional especially
after 15 weeks but the one thing is that
most of these states that have these
trigger laws ready to go once this uh
ruling is is
uh gone away with is total outright bans
even in the case of r word
and incest
and even in some cases of
a threat to the mother's [ __ ] safety
yeah no like you're absolutely correct
like if the baby's growing in your
fallopian tube topic yeah you have a
stillborn you have to [ __ ] give birth
no there's like there's a bill
specifically that i thought was mental
because i was like this is insane
because ectopic pregnancies mean that
like the child is not existing like this
is not
there's no way that this uh you know
this this fetus can turn into a baby
and will 100 percent kill the carrier
they're like no you still have that it's
god's plan yeah god will god will
[ __ ] you know god will help you i
think christians should stop getting
chemotherapy or any preventative
treatment and stuff like that because
it's god's i agree just let it run baby
no that's what i said yesterday i was
like look if you're an originalist which
is [ __ ] by the way like the
textualist originalist interpretation of
the constitution is simply a way for you
to slap on some kind of intellectual
patina on your reactionary ideology it's
complete nonsense it's garbage suck me
if you are legitimately like oh i'm
unconstitutional i'm i'm taking
constitutional law right now and i'm
learning that originalism is like
legitimate it's not okay is it
illegitimate uh uh
you know pseudo-intelligent [ __ ]
[ __ ] way of going about things but
if you want to be an originalist
i should be able to kill you at the age
of 35 by injecting you with dysentery
i'm just saying like that's when that's
you know how it was supposed to be right
like we should be able to in a tribunal
legally speaking
you know [ __ ] say all right well you
have gangrene and we're going to saw off
your leg and let god sort it out that's
how they lived that's how the [ __ ]
founders lived you can't say like you
care about what they're what their words
meant i think syphilis should [ __ ]
kill you
yeah no you should die of syphilis you
should die of [ __ ] smallpox
no modern medicine like
it's wild diabetes it's wild that samuel
alito could go so far as to say well
abortions were never protected in the
constitution yet [ __ ]
chemotherapy wasn't either like you know
what i mean that's insane it's a medical
procedure it's such a dumb thing to say
like this document that was written like
over 200 years ago didn't specifically
mention
uh it's like bro how much whatever watch
dave rubin he's such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
ironically the question is the right one
again
can a company say hey if you work for us
and we are based in this state let's say
we are based in alabama i'm just using
that as an example and we are based in
alabama you have a health care policy uh
in alabama are you allowed to cross
state lines and get an abortion
elsewhere if it is not allowed in
alabama now of course this is the beauty
of the united states and again i would
say to barbara streisand and rosie
o'donnell and all of the blue czech
lefties rob reiner and mark hamill who
are the other really horrible ones give
me some horrible lefties
there's enough of them uh pick your own
horrible fd you at home choose your own
horrible hollywood lefty they can fund
people getting on buses and mostly it's
going to be poor people and mostly it'll
be people of color and they can bus them
into california and they can put them up
at the four seasons and they can have
their abortions and then they can send
them back because uh that's what they it
would be doing something with your own
money and your own reasons okay that's
the beauty of america okay i'm gonna
dude every time i listen to these
[ __ ] speak about this issue
it's like so hard for me not to violate
everything dave rubin is is the dumbest
of them no it's just
it puts me in [ __ ] red hot rage where
i'm just like
i i i'm thinking of such illegal things
right now in my mind and i'm trying to
stop myself from these urges but it's so
[ __ ] hard to
to just you know anyway i'm not gonna
say anything
but this idea that like oh if you're if
you're in alabama just get bussed over
to california beauty of america that's
the beauty of america it's like dude
holy [ __ ] first and i love how it goes
it's going to be poor people and black
people
who are going to need these services so
by the way i'm happy to say [ __ ] you
so you're going to have to rely on rich
people to bust your ass out take a nice
little [ __ ] holiday
to get an abortion so stop over at
disneyland how does that work how does
that work as like a libertarian by the
way like or or you know a classical
liberal how does that how do you how do
you live in that world yeah it's like if
the abortions are gonna happen
regardless why the [ __ ] can't they get
in alabama dumbass shut the [ __ ] up
isn't dave reuben they're like i believe
the less government the better
yeah the only person who like regularly
gets uh hate crimed by his own [ __ ]
fan base that yeah they don't even care
about it ben shapiro by the way once
famous or fed to dave rubin
i would not go i would not go to your
wedding uh i think it's abomination
against god and my religion would
prohibit me from attending even even a
birth even a anniversary party dude he
[ __ ] when he adopted a kid everyone
was like ew what the [ __ ] you're not
allowed to do that and it's like yeah i
mean if it were up to conservatives he
would not be able to
do that and honestly dave reuben
shouldn't be able to adopt kids not
because he's gay but because he's
[ __ ] dave rubin yeah yeah
like straight up if there was a way that
i could like write the rules i'd be like
no you do not deserve happiness or to be
able to [ __ ] raise a child this was
my other favorite take by matt gates
matt gate matt gates says what we always
thought he likes them dumb and young oh
yeah matt gates of course has a pending
investigation to offer like sex
trafficking minors giving them drugs and
stuff good guy he says how many
of the women rallying against
overturning roe are over-educated
under-loved millennials who sadly return
from protest to a lonely microwave
dinner with their cats and no bumble
matches what does over educated mean
i i think he's just he likes them you
know dumb i just find that is that an
insult over educated like
he's creating this idea that these are
like unfuckable
you know
cat ladies you know well you like some
dom and young stephen crowder said
something similar too
uh on his broadcast where he was just
like
you know it's always like ugly women
that complain about catcalling first of
all like that doesn't change anything
like you know
beauty is arbitrary all beautiful women
love being harassed and and uh and also
like no it doesn't matter like women get
cat called regardless of how you whether
you think they're hot or not i mean my
wife i would do this i wish my mom would
aborted me i think that's pretty funny
anti-natalist
who are you to judge her matt
you didn't consent to being born well i
mean matt gates he doesn't care about
consent
my wife hates being called uh
i'm pretty sure women do not like being
harassed on the streets by creepy men uh
but anyway a shout out to all the
over-educated women out there
uh via no he's just saying he he's doing
he's doing the thing that i was like
joking about where it's like oh you
don't you're unfuckable anyway like why
do you care about abortions it's like
dude if it doesn't matter okay
it literally doesn't matter because it
impacts them um clearly um
let's see
this this take was is [ __ ] real crazy
okay oh god i'm going to say i'm
literally so this guy
nick martin
we're testing we're testing the
boundaries of youtube terms of service
right now don't worry i've got uh here
oh it doesn't oh well i can cut the mics
and uh throw it okay peter brimelow the
former national review editor who now
runs the website vdare celebrated uh the
row news by posting on the alt social
media gab
next stop
brown versus board yeah
i mean that's that's that's all that's
always been their goal i mean this they
want they want segregation back
yeah of course dude what do you mean
well first of all
like they're they're v there's entire
[ __ ] mission strategy is like
i am
genuinely terrified of like a black or
brown person having sex with a white
person like that's their entire thing is
like no i didn't know that they didn't
go back to [ __ ] racial segregation
they are and also what do you think
private education is all about this is
literally what this is something that
the democratic party even has played a
role in with charter schools like a lot
of these
a lot of the reason why private
schooling is like such a big thing in
the republican party or school choice is
such a big thing in the republican party
is so that they can do this they want so
at a private school they can re they
cannot admit minorities well you know in
the united states of america you can uh
you can still have white supremacist
outcomes uh even if you even if you
parse through it on a class based
uh method in a you know classist way you
can still reach the same that's so wild
to say publicly
that's shocked me bro
yeah i mean there's there's uh um how do
i describe this so there's a polite way
of saying it and republicans say it
politely all the time and then this is
the most open like
polite way
the polite way of saying it i think is
that um
the polite way of saying is school
choice basically right
but for example like ben shapiro is
against the uh the voting rights act
here's ben shapiro saying that uh
uh
gay marriage as a right needs to be
overturned next
meanwhile the the democrats are really
trying to push particularly the
democrats in the media they've got abc's
terry moran saying that this is they
never know what they might do next what
are they going to do next my god the
supreme court they they might actually
go back and overrule loving versus
virginia and allow states to ban
inspirational matter there was a senator
who defended that
before this decision came out like
literally a month into racial marriage
dude what year is it man they will be
crazy they will absolutely do it let's
hear what ben has to say it wasn't even
based on the right to privacy idiots
that's based on the equal protection
clause wrong constitutional clause in
morons
and then they try to cloud well they
might overturn obergefell first of all
obergefell is a bad supreme court
decision and if we had a supreme court
with itself they would yeah obergfell is
the one that legalizes uh gay marriage
yeah
overturned old brookvale but they're not
going to they explain he's like i want
them to but they won't be separate in
that decision that i read in nearly his
totality on the air yesterday that this
has no impact
yeah and all those justices by the way
that trump appointed lied to the face of
congress and said we will not overturn
roe versus wayne they said it was a
super president yeah super president
multiple times so whatever the [ __ ] that
that piece of [ __ ] wrote and that
why would you why would you ever believe
them
in any meaningful capacity but why would
you especially try to believe them now
but ben knows ben knows he this is what
the future is
on the table this is what the federalist
society's stated purpose is is to like
uh sidestep
uh any matter of legislation make
legislation functionally impossible to
to happen
in the senate when the republican party
is the minority by you weaponizing the
filibuster and then sidestepping that
using state legislatures to like harm
people and also padding the deck
of the judiciary
to to uh enact these kinds of rules like
this was their goal and now they have a
super majority and they're and they're
they're expressing you know they're
they're finally doing what they've been
doing for the past 20 years
people don't realize the federal society
is so powerful they got george w bush to
change his supreme court appointment
like that's how [ __ ] and that's back
then they weren't even as big you know
they were just starting to pop off so
these guys are you know this is what
their slated purpose was and they're
doing this specifically for the white
evangelical protestant base of psychotic
zealots and and you know they're going
to keep doing it because they want to
win they want to win elections it's
scary though i wonder how far they want
to roll it back they want to go all the
way back to like 1860
free civil war of course that was the
golden days it's it's all a matter of
what is normalized right
these are two conflicting forces i'm
going to be super reductive here when
describing it but like reactionary
people they want to go back to a return
to tradition they want to go back to
traditional society right and it doesn't
matter how it like they will never stop
this is why fascism is inherently
self-defeating because there always has
to be an external force that you're
fighting against right um and and the
in-group gets smaller and smaller the
in-group has expanded greatly we have
hispanic people that we consider white
jewish people are considered white
polish people are considered white
slaves that are white in america that in
group
from a fascist perspective is slated to
get smaller if it's not consistently
expanding progressive ideology works in
the other side of this you have to put
your foot on the gas non-stop and make
sure that there is an endless sea of
progress so that republicans can fight
against that but when democrats refuse
to do so when democrats can't push for
more progressive legislation because
they're fearful or because they don't
want to then republicans are going to
take advantage of that and do what they
do best which is revert back and and
regress
um that's precisely why when joe biden
even brought up the idea that he could
by executive order
uh abolish student loan debt republicans
immediately hold on no that's bad that's
actually bad they immediately rushed to
fight against that but when democrats
don't give them something to fight
against they're going to do this this is
what they're going to do you have to
keep it
always
that's good that's interesting i mean
yeah it's so obvious that that's true if
you go back to
civil rights they were opposed you go
back to freeing the slaves they were
opposed everything that now they they
accept as norms of like well of course
that we would never we would never go
back never goes away that's the point
the resentment never goes away like
um
we have uh
four minutes left
so with that being said let's roll our
last slate here
better red than dead tucker carlson the
darling of the red the most popular
conservative media personality
put out this documentary about the death
of men go ahead roll it please
yes better read than dead this is not a
parody trailer this is a real [ __ ]
trick than that by the way is is the
opposite you know what red is there
right
his balls
well i mean
normally they say better dead than red
brother because oh i know red is
communism but
but now in this case he's talking about
the fall
of uh
testosterone yeah and his solution is to
tan your balls
to speak to the
people of america
about a subject which i believe to be
most important
and that is the subject of physical
fitness
jfk was fit and he [ __ ]
[Music]
true
but look what happened to him man this
is like jordan peter co this is brought
to you by jordan peterson where would we
be without
all i'm saying is maybe he should have
you know maybe he should have been
working out at the library to get his
head bigger or something okay jfk
what he had a big head all that no he
got
you you think his head could have been
strong more plated exactly
that's what i was saying he should have
got more more karma how he got a sticker
okay
turns out being a man doesn't protect
you from bullets losers oh yeah exactly
a country is as strong really as its
citizens and i think that mental and
physical health go hand in hand
hey tucker when's the last time you did
[ __ ] burpees
like that guy
you got the body of the [ __ ]
marshmallow man from ghostbusters like
shut up [ __ ] that point is awesome
though because like here's the thing
like didn't his family get rich selling
tv dinners like shut up [ __ ] yeah
swanson if anyone's making america fat
it's your family [ __ ] idiot
uh these guys rarely ever fit the
masculinity standards that they
wears a bow he's a little [ __ ] [ __ ]
i don't understand or i mean i do
understand it i think like because they
can't make it so they fake it and they
think like people will assume that you
fit the masculinity standards that
you're holding everyone else to just by
advocating for it but it's like you're
making things worse for you you know
what i mean why
why good times baby made weak men oh no
biden
he's a weak man he fell down the stairs
you all did you see that is also kind of
like i mean his brain is no good but
he's out he's like pretty fit dude joe
joe is pretty alpha he's just like
[ __ ] 100 years old yeah and by the
way
he challenged trump to a push-up
competition remember yeah
oh yeah
and by the way i wish he did that most
people his age when they fall down the
stairs they break a [ __ ] hip and die
joe biden he bounces up and he went up
that end of that bucket baby that's
brandon
i love this though weak man ah that
[ __ ] stumbled there is nothing uh i
think uh more unfortunate pesticides
what is that one for hey we used to
squirt our [ __ ] crops with deadly
pesticides so
that there's nothing uh what the [ __ ] is
this supposed to mean there's a there's
an ounce of truth to it the pestis not
the pesticide specifically they think
that harms in different ways but like
um
the the reality is like america has an
obesity epidemic that's true um
and and also many other states actually
shouts out to europe they're now
starting to have an obesity epidemic too
[ __ ] you europe yeah guess what suck me
okay yeah you made fun of us
the americans are fat guess what you're
fat too now yeah i mean everyone's fat
because our brain poison uh impacts
everybody and our delicious uh horrible
substances that we put in our uh food is
by the way too cheap for other companies
to avoid
i i know we have known a lot of time all
i was gonna say is there is a noticeable
decline in testosterone and it is
related to how dog [ __ ] our agricultural
production is and our standards are and
that's why we have like well nobody
really knows why it could be that that
we're drinking plastics yeah
microplastics
it's probably diet it's probably plastic
it's probably the air we breathe i mean
i don't think people know why
testosterone levels are dropping
but shout out to this random kid who
they just [ __ ] put on blast yeah
that's [ __ ] up dude like check out
this young fat loser
fortunate and they have a soft chubby
fat looking children
shout out jfk dude a great shooter man
back then you could just say what the
[ __ ] you wanted yeah that all of you
will shut out this fat dude it's just
they plastered on the tv somebody in the
united states to make sure that our
children participate fully wait so
they're in favor of cleaning up the
environment because that no they just
here they show plastic in the water dude
they just got out they use it as a pad
the decks like
nope we got we they're right let's just
strengthen the epa i know but that's the
tucker carlson strategy he'll never say
that he'll never say we need to look at
he's saying he's right here's
no no no the plastic's in the water we
got to clean it up he's right our
children participate fully in a vigorous
and adventurous life which is possible
for wait what is this week man
he's saying they're they're [ __ ] for
kneeling for black people i think yeah
what's the weak what's weak about this
one
they all look like skinny legends
no they're they're saying like they're
wearing masks and they're that's why
they're scared of covid which is you
know weak and also they're kneeling i
think for black people so that makes
them doubly weak weak and dumb yeah
yeah they're just like you know you're
weak it's possible for them in this very
rich country about
there's been wait weak men make hard
times that that dude on the ground who's
like pretzeled is literally some [ __ ]
republican guy who got a [ __ ] pushed in
because he ran outside with a [ __ ]
katana to defend his favorite bar he was
like some uh some neurodivergent dude
who like it's hard times for him
yeah but that's not exactly are they
showing him as like a liberal or
something no it's a hard time for that
man he had to defend his rights with the
katana bro also i have such bad brain
disease that i just i can look at a
snippet like that and just immediately
tell you he recognized that one yeah
a 50 decline in sperm counts
in uh the last 40 years along with a
precipitous decline in testosterone look
at them titties boy yeah let's [ __ ]
go
i have a rune tattoo because like that
don't that don't look like
a leftist to me
wait a what
the tattoo on his arm it's a ruined
oh but look at them titties boy okay i
didn't know this was not safe for work
yeah in production we're headed for a
calamity and that's not hyper bro
whatever clap you need to worry about
whatever is going on with your voice
which are you worrying about with the
calamity bro stop whatever you're doing
the problem here is that like they're
not this is what republicans do
republicans do this [ __ ] so well where
they like identify a problem and it's
true like testosterone levels are
declining and that does lead to health
complications both for women and men
that's not like an automatically good
thing
but they will rarely ever try to solve
it or even analyze it at a systemic
level and then hyper focus on like it's
because you know gay people live
alongside straight people openly now or
some other like dumb [ __ ] that they
focus
they whip you up in a frenzy for real
issues and then they hyper focus all of
your anger into
this well no he does have a good
solution which we're getting too all
right let's see what he has to do it's
not exaggeration and it's just a
mathematical fact bro stop and just
[ __ ] work on your own health dude
i'm in favor of uh a trt by the way
would you recommend a young man to tan
their balls
this is here's the solution yeah real
men
by the way oh you know it would be
perfect if they cut madison humping his
cousin in there oh my god dude i mean
that's like that that part i only saw
the last part of this and it's this is
the gayest [ __ ] i've ever seen here it
is
this is what tucker is recommending my
friends get that red light
right on your balls
madison humping his cousin look at these
like
muscular men sweating
hard iron sharpens iron as they say and
those hard times inevitably
produce men who are tough men who are
resourceful men who are strong enough
what's he drinking
raw eggs my man
i love give me that chicken cup
yo this is straight up the last leg of
this is straight up a trailer for
[ __ ]
gay porn 100
i mean this is look at this shot
this is it's awesome i mean maybe this
will get dudes to be more in touch with
them
with their sexuality like this
okay but this is
incredibly gay
there's nothing more unfortunate said
the president of the united states on
camera than quote soft chubby fat
children
yeah that was jfk you should you should
bring up some of the other things people
were saying around that time too yeah
let's just not ex let's just not do it i
don't even think tucker would be fond of
jfk regardless by the way that man has
got a [ __ ] killer double chin i'm
just saying like there's there's all
flop there no definition it's jfk legacy
they don't tell you about but that was a
common view
but he didn't like fat kids no i mean
look i'm in favor i'm in favor of yeah
the
fundamentally important part of
oh you yeah it i think i'm in favor of
getting healthy i'm in favor of
addressing everybody knows that
everybody knows that yeah i mean
it's just it's frustrating when like
republicans you know
try to take on this position and then
like they have you seen chris christie
no there's i mean republicans are not
healthy chris christie okay that man was
filmed putting a smaller bag of eminem's
sporting it into a bigger bag of
eminence okay i respect that though that
was a response i'm just saying
uh it's not a political issue i've seen
lots of hogs
no i mean if you go to that man has a
bussy dude go to an oklahoma walmart if
you want to see what like real america
looks like okay [ __ ] looks like the the
wally end point that's true it's like
that's crazy uh to make this out to be
like something that liberals are
possible for uh mangina
okay
here you seen this man
i mean look this is what real masculine
went to school in new jersey i'm not
wait is that nsfw
if someone went to school in new jersey
like this is the peak that's my man
right there that's peak republican no
that's what that's what peak physical
specimens look like this yeah if you
don't know any peak male 1 you can't
accept this is what peak male
fitness looks like
then i can't help you and that man
boldly tucked it in there no [ __ ] anyone
out there yeah you know and by the way
donald trump
oh don't come for donald trump he's hot
i'm just standing here he's got a he's
got a fat one
donald trump dump truck yeah he has a
dumpy dude when he's playing tennis um
oh my lord
yeah so anyway we're out of time you i
know you gotta go
i know you guys oh it's the perfect uh
the fabinichi god stop what do you call
that the the frabernichi sequence with
sequence yeah yeah look at me perfect i
had a beat off
yeah he had a hole in one the other day
i'm so happy for him did he really
uh yeah i mean we don't know apparently
he had like a kim jong-un hole in one he
put out he put out a statement on it you
know
this is
the guy is stacked i mean i understand
what the lady is seeing
bro that aspie farting look at that his
hat is like flying off bro i'm not
aborting that ass i'm keeping the baby
yeah that's god damn what that butt do
[ __ ]
oh baby anyway so that's it we're done
yeah
men need to have cake and and donald
trump certainly has a whole ass bakery
you know what with donald trump you get
your cake and you get to eat it too
oh absolutely
um but yeah i all i was gonna say is
like i'm in favor of of becoming more
healthy but i think one of the main
reasons why we are so unhealthy and by
the way being overweight does not
automatically qualify unhealthiness
that's not what i'm saying so don't get
mad at me um
and and obviously like body shaming and
fat shaming is not an effective method
of losing weight and only makes you it
only makes the situation worse overall
but having said all that um a lot of the
problems are caused at the systemic
level whether it be the agricultural
subsidies that we offer to corn
uh that isn't in now every facet of our
food [ __ ] that we wouldn't even serve
[ __ ] that like in europe uh they would
not even give to their their cattle
as feed is something that we eat on a
daily basis
and i'm sure that that has a significant
more impact on the way we look or
testosterone levels or anything like
that the microplastics especially then
then i don't know whatever the [ __ ]
republicans are trying to point the
finger everybody knows being fat isn't
good for you nobody wants to be fat
it's a complicated issue
there's a lot of ends and a lot of outs
yeah
okay
all right are we ending it on that note
guys thanks for watching
leftovers is back hope you enjoy we'll
be back
every thursday at 10 a.m live hell yeah
from the 10 trillion dollar studio
we have black water posted outside we
have surface-to-air missiles do not [ __ ]
with us yep we are coming
and we are pissed off
that's right brother
[Music]
you